bienvenue pour le 7-8 l'actu sur
téléphiles 78 le journal de la rédaction
le tour de l'actualité locale de ceux ci
jouent mais aussi comme chaque vendredi
les principales informations à retenir
de cette semaine voici les titres il ya
70 ans sur les plages de normandie non
loin d'ici débarquer les alliés les
commémorations se sont déroulées tout au
long de la journée et lors des défilés
des versailles et étaient aussi présents
une association locale a travaillé sur
la rénovation de plusieurs voitures
militaires trois ans de travaux et
l'hôpital privé de l'ouest parisien
dispose maintenant d'une extension de
5000 m² nous verrons ce que cela va
changer en matière d'offre de soins pour
la population et puis nous reviendrons
sur la réforme territoriale la
disparition programmée des conseils
généraux sur la contestation face aux
rythmes scolaires avec la mère de
plaisir qui lance monde sans ironie
l'idée de récré hamon ou encore sur
l'application pour smartphone lancé par
hf prévention pour trouver simplement un
préservatif
l'image du jour pour débuter et qui nous
ramène à ce 24 août 1944 cette
libération que vous allez le voir de
versailles occupée comme le reste de la
france par l'allemagne nazie
clin d'oeil à l'histoire en ce 6 juin
jour de commémoration du débarquement
des troupes alliées en normandie et pour
ces commémorations justement à des
versailles et se sont impliqués leur
association envoyés sur place pour les
défilés une trentaine de véhicules
militaires le reportage de mathilde qu'à
berne et de hattrick jacques de dixmude
dans ces hangars sont entreposés des
véhicules militaires une trentaine de
ces engins est parti en normandie pour
participer au défilé du 6 juin presque
une routine pour l'association créée au
début des années 80 par une bande de
copains univers compte aujourd'hui une
centaine d'adhérents
récupération réparation présentation
plus qu'une passion c'est un véritable
devoir de mémoire le devoir de mémoire
nous continuerons à le faire quand il y
a par exemple des dates
on peut dire que ce sont des dates
mythique que ce soit lé le
le 8 mai fin de la guerre de 40 5 le 6
juin le 18 juin la libération de paris
etc on nous demande l'association se
concentre uniquement sur les véhicules
de la seconde guerre mondiale
particulièrement ceux qui ont participé
au débarquement beaucoup sont américains
et britanniques
alors le premier à 7 à 8
une automitrailleuse avec un canon 37
très très légère et qui roule disons
bien elle était très très utilisé par
les armées américaine et la 2e db en
tout terrain ça roule très bien léger
rapide à côté vous avez le deuil qui est
en restauration
parce que ce véhicule a dû à mon avis
être un petit peu utilisé dans d'eau de
mer et l'eau de mer si on ne l'a pas
aussitôt à grande eau oxydes le sel
restent dans les oméga de côté alors
après c'est un travail de titan
l'association possède une cinquantaine
de véhicules le travail est permanent
comptait près de 2000 heures pour
restaurer une voiture militaire en
normandie les véhicules défilent ce 6
juin sur omaha beach accompagné d'une
fanfare américaine
je vous propose à présent d'écouter un
témoignage celui de josette de manille
trappistes durant la guerre elle est
emmenée avec sept membres de sa famille
en normandie 1 là bas la vie dit elle
est plus douce qu'en ville la nourriture
plus abondante aussi une vie plutôt
sereine jusqu'à ce jour du 6 juin 1944
et elle revient pour nous sur cette
période et puis le 6 juin lors on était
dans le jardin ce matin là et on
entendait les canons les canons et le
cousin qui nous avait hébergé les nous
cherchons en disant maman vous restez
pas tout seul il ajouté vous revenez à
la maison on était dans une petite
maisonnette qui nous avaient trouvé à
peu près à 400 mètres de chez lui et
vous restez
alors il a mené le rhône aux affaires
dans une chapka et et puis si vous
voulez
on était comme qui dirait lanoux et puis
ont traversé des champs pour aller dans
le sur la route de l'autre côté et là on
a été pris en chasse par un avion maman
mes frères et moi et puis les baleines
nous siffler de chaque côté et nous on a
couru très vite alors se diriger vers
les cachets et on attend d'une bonne
heure et puis après le monsieur qui
était juste dans le de l'autre côté du
chemin il est venu nous chercher la dyle
ça qu'il n'y ait plus rien et on est
rentré chez lui et puis après bon les
hommes se sont mis à construire des
abris on était 30 dans l'abri et puis on
a été pris comme ça quand ils ont voulu
libéré la ville enfin le village disons
on était pris entre les deux feux entre
le village d'avant est le nôtre on
entendait les obus sifflé tout est là où
on nous avait appris à mettre les
ouvriers sur la tête pour éviter les
éclats et puis nous ont laissés dans
l'abri parce que ce n'était pas encore
un truc réd il avait peur que les
allemands reviennent et de la pâte les
américains sont arrivés ils nous ont mis
dans une cave pendant encore huit jours
en normandie on n'a pas subi ce que les
gens ont su bien parce que c'est un
cross quand même ce qu'ils ont vécu
mais nous on arrivé là juste pour se
protéger on
n'a pas été gâté mais je trouve que
c'est ça devrait pas exister il ya
cocteau vont encore toutes les guerres
qu'il ya maintenant les gens ne sont pas
contents ils ont rien compris
c'est pas possible
l'hôpital privé de l'ouest parisien fait
peau neuve à trappes l'établissement a
inauguré sa nouvelle extension ainsi que
la rénovation de son ancien bâtiment des
travaux de près de trois ans points qui
permettent d'améliorer son accessibilité
et sa capacité à répondre aux besoins
des patients avant de recevoir en
plateau à nos invités pour en parler
plus en détail voici le point sur les
principales nouveautés avec yolande
torres jonathan vilma n'est sébastien
combes
nous voici à trappes dans les nouveaux
locaux de l'hôpital privé de l'ouest
parisien une extension de cinq mille
mètres carrés inauguré jeudi cette
extension elle était nécessaire pour le
développement notre établissement
puisque on était en manque et de
capacités ça nous a permis également de
cette indispensable pour moderniser
notre plateau technique
cette extension c'est presque trois ans
de travaux et un investissement de près
de 30 millions d'euros ici dans cette
nouvelle unité de dialyse on est passé à
24 postes au lieu de 15 auparavant et de
nouveaux services sont développées une
modernisation bien accueillie par les
médecins
c'est d'abord le confort pour les
patients je crois qu'il faut mettre ça
en premier avec
l'ergonomie pour les soignants c'est à
dire un lieu agréable où on est motivé
pour délivrer des soins de bonne qualité
pour
échanger avec les patients ça a été
l'occasion de renouveler des matériels
de traitement donc on a maintenant des
générateurs de dialyse d un traitement
d'eau qui permet de délivrer une dialyse
d'une dune tout à fait d'une excellente
qualité ici dans le service de
réanimation polyvalente et de
surveillance continue on est passé d'une
capacité de huit à quinze lits canton
plateau technique d'imagerie médicale il
est maintenant regroupées sur un même
lieu comprenant deux scanners est
deuxième
le bloc obstétrical a lui aussi été
repensé avec notamment quatre salles de
naissance au lieu de trois auparavant
une structure nouvelle qui a également
permis de rénover les anciens locaux
existants en à rénover certains services
comme la médecine l'accueil qui est
nouveau notre bloc opératoire a été
totalement rénové et il ya eu également
des espaces de consultation cet hôpital
privé établissements de générale de
santé compte 430 salariés et 110
praticiens
et je reçois présents pour parler de ces
nouveautés de ces travaux béatrice co
bonsoir vous êtes directeur du pôle ile
de france ouest de générale santé est
également elisabeth triesman bonsoir 7
directeur délégué de l'hôpital de priver
de l'ouest parisien 22 mille mètres
carrés c'est donc la superficie totale
de votre établissement aujourd'hui 5000
de plus qu'auparavant on vient
d'entendre les raisons de ce changement
mais pour bien préciser les choses
aujourd'hui il était indispensable de
faire ces travaux c'est une vraie
nécessité c'est une nécessité absolue
la médecine évolue vite les équipements
matériels également et cet hôpital avait
40 ans donc il a subi un certain de
restructuration au fil des années mais
nous en étions à un point où il était
nécessaire de faire une nouvelle
réanimation d'agrandir notre service de
dialyse et de proposer aux jeunes mamans
et nouveau service de maternité avec des
salles plus performante à côté d'une
salle de césarienne ce qui c 'est ce qui
sécurise complètement le circuit de la
naissance et avec à présent une néo
natologie avec 6 berceau donc qui
permettent d'accueillir des enfants de
petits pois des enfants qu'ils ont pas
tout à fait mature et qui de ce fait
peuvent rester chez nous et ne plus être
transféré dans un autre centre donc
c'est un plus aussi pour toutes ces
jeunes mamans peut-être une question que
peuvent se poser les passions et les
patientes en l'occurrence est-ce que ça
aura une incidence sur le prix des soins
parce que ça change quelque chose aucune
aucune incidence donc un des points
forts de l'hôpital privé l'ouest
parisien trappe c'est effectivement la
prise en charge de tout le monde tous
les patients assurés sociaux les
personnes qui sont à la cmu les
personnes qui bénéficient de l'aide
médicale d'état donc nous accueillons
tout le monde et nous efforçons de faire
des circuits de soins sans dépassement
d'honoraires cet hôpital privé attraper
le seul du secteur sur saint quentin en
yvelines cet historique s'est elle hier
à la naissance de l'agglomération de la
vie nouvelle il n'y a pas d'hopital
public est-ce que ça a une influence a
une influence une incidence sur vos
missions est ce que vous êtes obligés de
garder ouverts certains services même
s'ils ne sont pas rentables ah oui donc
on assure des services déjà dans un
service d'urgence est ouvert 24 heures
sur 24
il faut savoir que l'hôpital privé de
res parisien on a on a su réussir un
pôle de sécurité où on a tous les soirs
animateur sur place un médecin
urgentiste et à l'anesthésiste donc un
effet où il y en a sur ses services de
mission de service public en permanence
et au quotidien c'est à dire qu'il ya
des obligations de l'état est ce que
l'état regarde ce que vous faites est ce
que les conventions qui seront signées
alors la santé est très réglementée
qu'elle soit public privé privé à but
non lucratif nous répondons tous aux
mêmes normes et aux mêmes conditions de
fonctionnement que nous impose le code
de santé publique et sur l'ouverture
besoin de certaines filières branche
spécialisée tous et insoumis tout est
soumis à autorisation pour ouvrir un
établissement de santé pour créer des
services pour créer des activités pour
les poursuivre nous sommes constamment
contrôlé nous déposons des dossiers et
nous sommes agréés en quelque sorte par
nos ministères de tutelle et par l'
agence régionale de santé
d'ile-de-france qui nous contrôle
permanent quels sont les spécialités
couverte aujourd'hui sur cet
établissement
alors quasiment toutes les spécialités
nous sommes un vrai hôpital local
avec de la chirurgie de la médecine de
la cancérologie
de l'imagerie médicale dont la dialyse
la réanimation dont qui sont des
services supports nous faisons également
également un service sos mains qui est
extrêmement précieux pour notre secteur
d'activité nous faisons quasiment tous
j'en reviens aux travaux à cette
extension cette rénovation vous avez dû
recruter forcément par le sourd de
pénurie de manque de médecins de
spécialistes étaient difficiles
alors quand une activité est existante
qu'il y a un noyau dur de praticiens
qu'il exerce depuis longtemps les jeunes
mettaient envie de rentrer dans des
équipes nos coqs équipe est stable quand
elle est bien constitué nous avons
beaucoup moins de difficultés à recruter
des jeunes médecins concurrence entre
les établissements society pour les
faire venir
oui mais il ya la concurrence partout
sur tous les secteurs et puis les outils
de travail comme vous l'avez fait c'est
aussi un supplémentaire la sécurisation
des conditions de travail de nos équipes
capitale le matériel qui est mis à
disposition et capitale donc
effectivement c'est très attractif pour
des équipes médicales on nous dit que le
patient était au coeur de ce projet de
rénovation extension aujourd'hui vous
avez faciliter au maximum la fluidité de
la prise en charge car ça se passe très
vite aujourd'hui y'a pas d'attentes
bonne analyse va par exemple au niveau
de nos urgences on analyse tous les mois
les temps d'attentes au niveau des
changements parce que c'est quelque
chose qui nous tient à coeur on souhaite
vraiment organisé cdc prise en charge et
puis oui je pense que on a par exemple
un circuit jeu circuit sos mais la prise
en charge sos mains c'est un circuit où
rapide prise en charge cancer la
prévention du cancer du sein également
aux natures oui vous avez créé une prise
en charge rapide donc la patiente qui a
une mine une mammographie est angoissé
savoir si elle a un module pas là dans
la foulée elle peut bénéficier d'une
échographie d'une ponction et avoir les
résultats sous 48 heures donc voilà un
circuit court par exemple de prise en
charge à vous parler des urgences 50
1900 passage en 2013 comment ils feront
en hausse oui la fréquentation des
vacances oui on vient pour tout et pour
rien quelquefois c'est sont encore
annoncées quelquefois pour des petits
bobos aux urgences c'est la gronde
grosses urgences mais c'est aussi
l'urgence ressentie et on s'efforce de
s'occuper aussi l'urgence ressentie
parce qu'elle a également son importance
sur plan de la fréquentation justement
comment se situent ces sept
établissements sur les 75 que vous gérez
pour général t c'est un gros
établissement c'est un gros
établissement oui au niveau de la
générale de santé tous les
établissements qui s'appelle hôpital
privé sont des gros établissements qui
en plus de 100 lits et là nous avons 300
lits dans la question les pistes de
développement peut-être est-ce que vous
avez puisque vous nous disiez en
introduction que il faut régulièrement
s'adapter que la médecine évolue très
vite on pensait déjà à l'avenir il ya
des services nouveaux qui peut bien sûr
l'avenir le présent donc nous avons par
exemple acquis récemment dans le cadre
de cette extension un laser greenlight
qui permet de traiter les adénome de la
prostate
en ambulatoire ce qui n'était pas le cas
avant donc nous favorisons beaucoup
toutes les techniques qui peuvent
favoriser l'ambulatoire aujourd'hui nous
faisons 60 % de notre activité en
ambulatoire c'est un vrai plus pour le
patient qui rentrent le matin qui sort
le soir qui peut revenir dans
l'établissement si la moindre doute la
moins deux problématiques il un numéro
d'urgence c'est tout à fait sécurisant
et une hospitalisation diminue le nombre
d'hospitalisations dit dans la libérer
aussi les lys il ya saturation dans les
établissements oui absolument mais si
ceux ci une recommandation du ministère
maintienne à toutes les deux d'être venu
en plateau à l'hôpital privé de deux
trappes qui fait donc peau neuve vous en
savez un peu plus maintenant sur les
offres qui sont proposés
comme chaque vendredi à présent en
retour sur l'essentiel de la semaine
parmi les principales informations les
annonces du président hollande sur la
réforme territoriale 14 régions au lieu
de 22 actuellement dans un souci
d'économie d'efficacité l'île de france
n'est pas concernée vous le savez ces
frontières ne vont pas changer seulement
parmi les annonces du président figure
aussi des intercommunalités plus peuplé
la disparition des départements aussi
réaction explications olivier minne
scalco
14 régions au lieu de 22 dans les tuyaux
depuis quelques mois la réforme
territoriale a enfin livré son verdict
via une tribune de françois hollande
publié ce mardi dans la presse
quotidienne régionale si six régions
resteront telles qu'elles comme
l'ile-de-france où la bretagne d'autres
vont fusionner midi-pyrénées et
languedoc-roussillon alsace et lorraine
ou encore le trio centre poitou
charentes et limousin le but de cette
réforme transforme l architecture
territoriale et faire des économies avec
moins d'élus en supprimant dès 2020 les
conseils généraux les premières
réactions à cette annonce ne se sont pas
fait attendre si du côté de jean paul
huchon président socialiste de la région
ile de france on salue une vision
ambitieuse pour le pays du côté de
l'opposition les échos sont tout autres
pour valérie pécresse présidente du
groupe ump au conseil régional d'île de
france cette réforme n'est qu'une
manoeuvre pour gagner du temps et éviter
une déroute aux élections cantonales et
régionales initialement prévue en mars
2015 est repoussée à l'automne 2015 pour
olivier lebrun conseiller général ump
des yvelines à cette réforme est loin
d'être une priorité pour les français je
pense pas que le problème des régions
des 22 régions de 14 soit le vent le
problème auquel soient confrontés les
français et françaises qui demandent
actuellement c'est du boulot de
l'activité économique forcément de
l'emploi et ce n'est pas en changeant ça
que ça va changer les choses pour
l'instant on met devant la charrue avant
les boeufs moi je pense encore c'est un
effet d'annoncé et puis derrière on fait
ça fera sa trompe chiites comme comme
beaucoup de choses qui sont annoncés
depuis maintenant deux ans
il faut essayer de de simplifier un
petit peu tout et les flops comme netapp
réalité département région état pour le
citoyen se retrouver tout ça c'est quand
même une partie n'est pas une partie de
plaisir beaucoup à cette réforme les
élus ou dans les citoyennes mais le
travail qu'il valait mieux que
certains
cette nouvelle carte de france sera voté
au plus tard à l'automne 2014 en
attendant elle suscitera les débats
entre ministres et sénateurs dès la fin
du mois de juin
et puis une autre réaction celle de
pierre bédier le président du conseil
général des yvelines président ump pour
qui il faut maintenir la proximité des
élus ils souhaitent conserver cet
échelon départemental notamment dit il
afin de soutenir plus aisément les
maires en études à l'assemblée cette
semaine le projet de loi relatif à la
prévention de la récidive et
l'individualisation des peines un projet
porté par la garde des sceaux christiane
taubira plus communément appelée réforme
pénale à la prison de bois d'arcy où les
agents de probation chargés d'aider les
détenus à se réinsérer gère plus de 100
dossiers chacun où l'on compte 835
condamné pour seulement 500 lits place
on salue l'idée de développer les
bracelets électroniques pour les peines
de moins de cinq ans même si le syndicat
ufap pointe un manque de garanties
financières dans cette réforme on
s'inquiète aussi de la reconstruction
des victimes si l'agresseur n'est pas
incarcéré et puis à la prison de bois
d'arcy toujours un nouveau détenu vient
d'arriver cette semaine mais dit ne
mouge tireur présumé dans la sphère de
la tuerie au musée juif de bruxelles il
a été présenté par deux fois déjà devant
la juridiction de versailles il a
d'ailleurs refusé cette semaine son
extradition vers la belgique nouvelle
audience prévue la semaine prochaine le
12 juin
éducation à présent avec les gilet jaune
qui battent le pavé ce collectif de
parents d'élèves vient cette semaine de
mobiliser à maurepas contre
l'application des nouveaux rythmes
scolaires une mobilisation alors que le
maire ump faisait voter au même moment
une demande de report du décret une
décision approuvée avec une large
majorité on écoute grégory gare et
astier le maire qui était présent sur ce
plateau jeudi soir g j'ai obtenu 29 voix
sur 33 une partie de l'opposition s'est
même joint à se veut donc ce qui prouve
que ce n'est pas une décision
idéologique mais qui est centrée
vraiment sur l'intérêt de l'enfant et je
m'y oppose parce que premièrement nous
n'avons pas les moyens financiers
d'appliquer cette réforme malgré la
dotation de l'état même si l'état
versera 50 euros à 50 euros alors que
amour passé 200 euros par enfant donc il
faut que la collectivité qu'on pense et
comment fait-on pour compenser il faut
augmenter les impôts et je refuse
d'augmenter les impôts des mauriciens
c'est une aberration économique
familiale éducative au détriment du
bien-être de l'enfant et c'est pour ça
que nous demandons un report et une
pérennisation des moyens financiers pour
appliquer de manière qualitative c'est
très forme mais je reviens sur l'école
le mercredi matin que vous ne voudrais
pas me dit il n'y aura pas d'école vous
n'appliquerait pas cette réforme va y
avoir une difficulté pour les
enseignants les enseignants leur
responsable hiérarchique l'inspection
académique va leur dire vous devez
dispenser les cours on est vous dans les
écoles mais qu'il donne les moyens les
écoles seront fermées mais qu'il donne
les moyens nécessaire de le faire je
n'ai pas recruté d'animateurs également
pour animer les activités périscolaires
comment on va faire l'état c'est une
question comment va faire l'état dans
une arène pas les moyens à ma part
d'appliquer cette réforme le bras de fer
se poursuit absolument à ce jour treize
communes sur les 262 que compte le
département refuse de mettre en place
donc cette réforme elles n'ont pas remis
leur copie au directeur académique le 20
juin il sera trop tard le conseil
départemental de l'éducation nationale
va entériner définitivement les projets
si aucun dossier n'est déposé les
horaires seront donc imposer les maires
devront s'est pliée et expliquer à leurs
administrés l'organisation ou non
d'activité ou plus simplement d'un
simple système de garderie d'ailleurs
c'est finalement ce choix qui a été
retenue par la mère de plaisir opposés à
la réforme elle invente non sans ironie
la récré amont du soir de 16h à 16h30
elle s'est expliquée sur cette antenne
alors aujourd'hui comme je le dis
souvent il ya deux casquettes en rien la
casquette de l'élu qui te peut que
constater l'échec de cette mise en place
de ce décret et puis il ya le
gestionnaire de la ville avec la tempe
des parents de savoir comment ça va se
passer à la rentrée et donc après une
grande discussion très longue avec
l'inspecteur d'académie et bien nous
avons trouvé un moyen de passages dirais
pour donner un peu de sérénité aux
familles plaisir oasis est ce que j'ai
annoncé cette semaine mais nous ferons
une récréation je dirais un encadrement
des enfants entre 16h et 16h30 pour que
les parents qui ont besoin de venir les
chercher à 16h30 et bien puisse le faire
et ensuite nous prendrons le relais avec
les centres de moi cyr et puis bien sûr
tout ce qui est soutien se trouvait
trouver un préservatif un centre de
dépistage ou tout simplement obtenir des
conseils pratiques hf prévention vient
de lancer en début de semaine tup une
application pour smartphone pour trouver
un préservatif et à l'occasion du
lancement de cette application nous
avons reçu en plateau jérôme andré
président d'hachette prévention il est
revenu sur cet autre actualité la
censure dans les yvelines et dans une
commune du pec dans la commune du pecq
de la fiche d'un joaillier de luxe une
affiche où l'on voit une femme embrasser
son doublé qui aurait choqué selon le
maire une partie de la population une
censure qui intervient une dizaine de
jours après la publication d'un rapport
pendant que vous découvrez donc cette
affiche elle ce rapport pointe
l'augmentation depuis un an des actes
homophobes entre agressions verbales les
violences physiques
c'est nous qui sommes effectivement
choqué je vois pas où est le mal en tout
cas il ya rien de pornographique
là-dedans fait valoir un peu arrêtez de
stigmatiser tout ce qui ne plaît pas
donc au maire du pecq le maire du pecq
donc doit comprendre que ces habitants
qui se plaignent mais il ya aussi une
grande majorité qu'il est sans précédent
à gaza et sur une affiche de film océans
ou la fiche avait il y avait eu aussi
impressionnant chez eux effectivement
pour les gars les garçons du lac est
effectivement donc y avait eu censure
nous on pense que tout ça c'est vraiment
du grand n'importe quoi c'est plus
possible d'avoir de l'homophobie en
france avec les gens se rendent compte
que le mage pour tous ces actes et donc
on n'en parle plus ça a libéré donc la
parole de certains ça veut dire que le
débat a été mal mené à l'époque l'année
dernière très malmenés en parler
différemment mais à passer par un
référendum aussi pourquoi pas comme ça
il y aurait la légitimité du coma ce
délai
la réforme serait passer plus vite y
aurait moins de choses effectivement qui
se serait donc déroulé tout bêtement et
et puis en l'occurrence ça fait beaucoup
débat sauf que effectivement il ya eu
beaucoup de mariages qui se sont passées
preuve que effectivement ça répondait à
des vraies préoccupations
on a le choix maintenant donc quand on
est homosexuel de pouvoir se marier ou
non et c'est donc un choix laissons le
choix aux gens pour une fois c'était une
loi qui ne retirait rien à personne mais
qui ajoutait fin du journal de ceux ci
je vous retrouverai mardi profitez bien
de ce nouveau jour férié si vous en avez
l'occasion bon week end